this video came out this is President
Joe Biden back in January basically
making a threat and it sort of seems
like it's come true
let me answer the first question first
if Germany if uh if Russia invades that
means tanks or troops crossing the uh
the border of Ukraine again then there
will be uh we there will be no longer on
North stream too we we will bring it
into it
would you what how would you how will
you do that
exactly
since the project and control of the
project is within Germany's control
we will
I promise you we'll be able to do it
you get what's going on here I mean this
is really nuts and this is where it's so
disappointing that we don't have a
mainstream media that will honestly
assess these issues and go back to
videos this is why we do the show the
way we do it and why I always jump to
old clips and everything because you
have to start looking at the past to
understand the future or certainly
understand the present right so Biden is
saying this is back in January he's
saying if Russia goes into Ukraine and
we know Russia has gone into Ukraine
we're going to end the pipeline then
suddenly this past Monday the pipeline
blows up in four spots the Swedish Coast
Guard on Thursday said it's discovered a
fourth unexplained gas leak in the
undersea nordstream pipelines linking
Russia to Europe and as gas Rose to the
surface allegations of sabotage flew
between Brussels Moscow and Washington
the European Union is investigating the
cause of the leaks in the Nordstrom one
and two pipelines under the Baltic Sea
and has said it suspects sabotage to
which it promised a quote robust and
United response but it has not said who
is to blame and now we've got our usual
swamp creature saying Russia blew up its
own pipeline like
this war or whatever this thing is it's
hard to even call it a war because we're
not in a declared war of course and
we're just sending them all sorts of
money and we're arming everybody and all
that stuff but this this war that is
happening uh this very sort of ephemeral
War that's going on throughout the world
right now that's connecting United
States and Europe and all of these all
of these places across the globe
um it does seem like it's heating up and
did we just blow up this Pipeline and if
we did uh is Russia going to declare war
on us I mean it all sounds nuts but here
we are I suppose